tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates law
and order who's got it right the law
especially apply to you as Congress this
week debates how this country's police
forces should behave chokeholds laws
that officers escape criminal liability
we're joined by former black police
chiefs who hear it from both sides to
raise the bar it's not just good enough
today to do your job based on the gala t
plus we take a close look at the
far-right extremist Boogaloo glue
growing concern about how its members
have used racial justice protests as
cover for their violent attacks on law
enforcement and efforts to create riots
there is no evidence that these men had
any intention to join the demonstration
in Oakland as some of the media have
asked they came to Oakland to kill cops
and those coded 19 frauds the scammers
are having a field day with their phone
tricks and traps this gives them real
opportunity as you know scamming has
become big business it's cheap it's easy
Plus this week's winners and losers in
the media and I don't know who thought
it was a good idea to put 20,000 people
in a room see if you'll agree with all
the editors of me teait made their
judgments from the long crime trial
network this is Brian Ross inventor
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
Facebook live and YouTube live I'm
joined this evening by my colleague at
law and crime Rhonda Schwartz and Ronnie
we begin with a close look at a group
called Boogaloo that has emerged during
the racial justice protests a number of
men loosely affiliated with this group
have now been charged with carrying
weapons plotting attacks and actually in
one case carrying out at least two
murders Rhonda that's right Brian mixed
in with the protesters on social
injustice have been folks in the
Hawaiian shirts
sometimes armed members of this extreme
right-wing group that's become known as
boo
online they're often advocating for a
violent confrontation with authorities
even going so far as to discuss a second
civil war and this received a lot of
attention around the country as we saw
in this montage protests and rallies are
an opportunity for extremists to spread
their message through violence US
prosecutors say three boogaloo
extremists were heading to a protest in
downtown Las Vegas on May 30th to do
just that according to court documents
the three men were determined to incite
violence which included a plan to burn
police with Molotov cocktails during a
black lives matter protest that happened
Saturday in downtown Las Vegas but
they're accused of being part of an
anti-government extremist group known as
the Boogaloo movement a radical group
suspected to be spotted at protests
nationwide within the last week could be
in Colombia men and Hawaiian shirts
showing up at these protests lot
believes 24 year-old Joshua Bernard the
man he says is caught on video stealing
a police jacket from a patrol car could
be involved there's a lot of information
that he's part of the Boogaloo
organization it's a very radical group
their mission is to create a new civil
war the California Air Force sergeant
suspected in the ambush killing of a
Santa Cruz deputy is now charged in the
shooting death of a federal security
officer in Oakland now they say Steven
Carrillo was a passenger in the white
van at the time they say he used a
homemade machine gun in both of these
killings and that he appears to
sympathize with a group called Boogaloo
which is a fringe group that believes
there's an impending Civil War and
joining us now to talk about this are
two people who've done a lot of work on
this group Mia bloom professor at
Georgia State University and a
well-known expert in extremism and
terrorism and Robert Evans who writes
for belying the cat on online
investigations of this Boogaloo group
thank you both for being here
Mia let me start with you is it a real
threat or is it's so small that we
really don't have to pay much attention
to it well it is very small but I think
the thing to keep in mind is
as bill Barr and the president are only
focusing on and Tifa it is creating this
opportunity for extremists on the right
wing to operate in ways that are not
being focused by either the Justice
Department so we have to understand that
we can't fight this with one arm tied
behind our back in the same way that we
were over focused for almost 20 years on
the jihadi threat post 9/11 while while
these extreme right-wing groups emerged
and metastasized we have to be very
careful that as we're looking at groups
that are causing either chaos or
fomenting violence or exacerbating the
situation the boogaloo are a small group
you have other small groups and so it's
not just Boogaloo but it also is a very
complicated picture because it
encompasses a lot of different types of
people that are wearing Hawaiian shirts
Robert Evans let me ask you you spent a
lot of time online trying to figure out
who these people are let's start by
asking why are they wearing Hawaiian
shirts well I mean it's just the way
kind of things evolved on the Internet
so boot the knit the term Boogaloo came
out of like an old movie from the 80s
break into electric Boogaloo and it was
a meme on the internet for a while when
something was like a sequel to do you
know whatever the name of that sequel
was to electric Boogaloo and then you
know back in around 2012 on a subset of
4chan people started doing that with the
idea of a second American Civil War so
Civil War two electric Boogaloo Boogaloo
SiC sounds kind of like big luau and
what are you wearing a luau you wear a
Hawaiian shirt so that's kind of the way
everything evolved do you see these men
who belong to this what drives them what
is their real motive here well you know
I for one thing I I don't think this is
either I don't think this is an
organization it's it's an aesthetic it's
it's an obsession with the idea of
collapse and and civil warfare within
the United States and I I think that the
the number of folks who are part of it
in an organized way and actually willing
to take action in the real world is very
very small but the number of folks who
ascribe to this who identify with this
kind of this move
who are obsessed with the idea of a new
civil war is actually quite large
there's a number of Facebook groups that
are in the tens of thousands of members
and so III do think what Mia Bloom said
is very relevant that sheep she
described it as metastasizing because I
do see this as almost more of it more
than an organization because it's not
really an organization a cancer on our
body politic it's evidence of a deep
sickness that there are so many
primarily young men in this country who
see no other option out of our current
political situation than mass violence
and who are taking steps to actively
prepare for it now for a lot of them
it's just because they want to dress up
as soldiers but a lot of them really do
believe this is coming and that again
it's it's evidence of a deep sickness
within our society and may you bloom a
question for you from LaRhonda Schwartz
how much of this is spreading on social
media Facebook and Twitter say they take
down posts that incite violence but are
these folks finding each other online
they are finding each other online and
what they'll do is they'll use different
hashtags so the moment that boogaloo
becomes too obvious they'll move to
something like goon twitter and with the
hashtag what ends up happening is what
we see in the open platforms the open
API what we would call maybe the surface
web is really a fraction of what's going
on so it's not just Facebook and Twitter
or YouTube where you can search these
but it's also the semi encrypted
platforms like telegram in these chat
semi encrypted chat platforms and then
also on the dark web and so what you end
up having is especially and this is
what's very concerning is a lot of the
people who are drawn to Boogaloo are
also perhaps formerly in the US military
and so they have the training they have
the weapons they have the lingo and they
have the contacts and so this is where
it becomes a little bit problematic
because on the one hand you have people
who have served the country but on the
other hand you have a subset of the
boogaloo that are also veterans and so
it becomes very complicated
in terms of freedom of speech you can't
clamp down on much of what's being said
and in fact what Facebook and Twitter
were able to do was they were able to
take down groups that are pretending to
be on Tifa that are actually right-wing
so when the boogaloo tried to evoke a
different group then maybe if they are
falsifying their identity that's one way
to take it down but you are you are
pushing up against the Terms of Service
of many of these service providers at
the same time most of the companies can
really only ban groups that are
designated as terrorist organizations
which are usually foreign groups and so
we don't have a domestic terrorism
statute becomes very complicated when
you're a Facebook or your Twitter trying
to figure out what is a violation of the
term of service versus what is free
speech mia you mentioned military
members the most serious case so far was
one that happened in Oakland California
were authorities have charged its three
men including an Air Force Staff
Sergeant in connection with the murders
of two law enforcement officers a
sheriff's deputy and a federal security
guard at the courthouse in Oakland
California this is how the US attorney
and the FBI described what happened
Carrillo elected to travel to Oakland to
conduct this murder and take advantage
of a time when this nation was mourning
the killing of George Floyd there is no
evidence that these men had any
intention to join the demonstration in
Oakland as some of the media have asked
they came to Oakland to kill cops
in addition cRIO appears to have used
his own blood to write phrases on one of
the cars that he carjacked the complaint
alleges that the patch and the phrases
written by Carrillo are associated with
the so called Boogaloo movement the
Boogaloo term is used by extremists to
reference a violent uprising or
impending civil war in the United States
and Robert Evans that was a very serious
case that I imagine it's still under
investigation
yes where do you think it leads well I
mean I here's part of the problem is
that again you're not talking about an
organization you were talking about an
obsession with an aesthetic and an
obsession with this idea of collapse and
it's possible to prosecute individuals
who have planning to carry out acts the
FBI recently busted three men who were
also veterans and also part of the
Boogaloo movement in Las Vegas who are
planning on carrying out a series of
attacks so you can bust little groups
like that but the problem remains that
you have this massive sizeable chunk of
people who kind of feed into these
little bitty groups and this is like the
surface chunk of the Boogaloo movement
which is largely on Facebook and other
social media apps but primarily Facebook
and that is sort of what radicalizes
people what what gets them kind of
obsessed with sharing these memes about
fighting the police fighting federal law
enforcement you know existing and living
in a way that they think is exciting in
like a post-civil war united states and
that's what draws new people in and I do
think the major feeder for this movement
is is Facebook it's what draws in this
large chunk of people a smaller group of
whom will actually carry out actions and
whatever Facebook is said about
attempting to reduce the spread of this
kind of content on their platform I have
seen no meaningful evidence that they've
taken real steps to change anything I
have a number of burner Facebook
accounts that I use that I join these
groups with in order to watch their
activity on the Internet and every
account that I start whenever I start
joining individual groups that are like
Boogaloo affiliated Facebook will
recommend me more and more extreme
groups store I'll start with a group
that maybe it's just kind of jokes for
them and they're sharing like more
lighthearted memes about the Boogaloo
and you know in two or three steps of
the recommendation algorithm I will be
looking at pages where people are like
talking about you know how to make bombs
and stuff it really does accelerate very
quickly and it accelerates because of
the way Facebook's recommendation
algorithm works
all right well Robert Evans thank you so
much for joining us I mean you bloom
both of you will want to get back to you
as this group continues to express its
views and perhaps turn to violence
thanks so much for being here both of
you thank you for having us coming up
you bet
coming up there may be a pandemic but
that hasn't stopped the scammers they're
busy as ever trading on people's fears
and trading on the disasters response
Act has made coronavirus testing more
accessible immediately if you want to
receive a free testing kit delivered
overnight to your home press 1 if you do
not want your free testing press 2
we continue now with a look at what's
happening for calls for police reform
and Rhonda Schwartz what's going on now
in Washington with Republicans and
Democrats squaring off with each with
their own plan that's right
they're at loggerheads on Capitol Hill
this week Democrats and Republicans not
agreeing on efforts for a police reform
bill they're arguing over things like
eliminating chokeholds that have proved
fatal or protections for police not to
be prosecuted widespread between the two
sides
absolutely it's become quite a political
issue here's how President Trump put it
in his rally last weekend we're going to
build a future of safety and opportunity
for Americans of every race color
religion and creed Republicans are the
party of liberty equality and justice
for all we are the party of Abraham
Lincoln and we are the party of law
and this is how reverend al sharpton saw
the issue of law and order the signals
that we're sending is that if you are in
law enforcement that the law doesn't
apply to you and I'm telling you that
the law order especially apply to you
because you're giving special powers
that others don't have we don't have a
badge representing the state we don't
have a gun we're carrying we've not gone
through training we should expect more
from you and if you break the law you
ought to be expected to pay an even
higher price we're joined now by RC
white the former police chief in Denver
and Louisville and a number of other
cities chief white thanks for being here
very much good morning so pleasure to
have the opportunity to speak with you
chief you here on one hand the president
the United States calling for a law and
order sometimes urging police to be
little rough with people they arrest and
are there other hand people calling for
the defunding of the police as one of
the most prominent black police
officials in the country you must be
hearing it from both sides how do you
react yeah you're correct
there is certainly different opinions on
there's a different opinion on what is
the best way to provide safety to our
citizens
fortunately I think that prior to these
most recent incidents maybe executives
in law enforcement in officers in law
enforcement I think we've taken the
steps in the right direction we just
need to continue to progress endeavor to
continue to progress in that direction
let's take a look at that video that's
now so well known to everyone of what
happened in Minneapolis to a George
Floyd chief that action you have said
you've told me before that's just not
acceptable how does it happen that that
takes place you know Ron I think you say
a matter
of culture officers really not
understanding some officers not
understanding the consequences of their
actions and working in an environment
where acceptable acceptable behavior
which it really was not acceptable has
been something that they've been
accustomed when you were chief you try
to bring reforms in both a Denver and
Louisville what was the biggest obstacle
for you in trying to reform those
departments and change the culture there
I think one of the biggest challenges is
understanding the expectation officers
expectations are they're training the
police academy on the legality of the
law I will see some procedures and they
go about doing their job with that in
mind the community's expectations are a
little different than that I think one
of the biggest challenges that we have
in law enforcement process country it is
also spanking they're they're doing
their job when they're gonna follow
these seizures communities are
challenging what these officers are
doing because they're really questioning
the necessity of those decisions you
know this is saying is just because as
legal doesn't make it necessary one of
the things that we absolutely have to do
in policing in addition to training
officers on the legality the law
policies or procedures we've got to
raise the bar it's not just good enough
today to do your job based on the galti
policies procedures you've got a factor
in the necessity of making those
decisions also chief another case that
received so much a chance in the last
few months took place outside Atlanta
I'm not Arbor II was shot by local white
residents police initially declined to
bring charges against the people who
shot a Matar berry yeah that's you know
that goes back to you know that's police
have been so accustomed to operating in
a certain fashion for so many years and
B you know and you are they're victims
of their value you know you could get
these officers are been on for 10 15 20
years and they're had the opportunity to
train some of these new officers so they
only they train them on what they've
been exposed to and now undid the bar
been raised rightfully so by the way
there's a different a different
expectation I tell you what I think we
really have to continue to do this
citizens want a voice and what we do and
how we do it and it's no longer accept
acceptable to say hey we have a crime
problem in your in your neighborhood and
these are the issues that we're doing to
justify empower that's not good enough
anymore now they want to know what the
crime problem is they want to know the
strategies that you're using to address
it and they want to sit at the table
with you to come up with those
strategies that are most effective for
their community
chief why do you used to be the chief in
Louisville Kentucky where the FBI and
others are now investigating what
happened in the case where a young woman
was shot in her own apartment and as
police carry out a no-knock warrant they
call it Brianna Taylor what do you make
of that case and how could that happen
as well were you aware of those kinds of
issues when you were the chief there
yeah no not once and certainly if you're
gonna do it it has to be under the most
extreme circumstances I would not
consider it no more I know not went
looking for drugs under the street sir
maybe if you had somebody it was morning
for a murder it was just no other way
that you can get that particular
individual and you knew that that person
was at that place at that particular
time and no other time that you know
that might justify it no one I know not
one but just philosophically speaking I
am Adam a pretty much Adam II opposed to
those little no not once and I think the
city of Louisville actually
outlaw those warrants in Congress this
week they are debating what to do about
police reform issues whether the
chokehold should be banned whether
police should no longer be given
qualified immunity which means they are
able to justify what they do because
they felt their lives are in danger
what do you what's your take on those
two issues chuckles should been banded
years ago it's been banded and and
several other departments particularly
should have been been so that that is a
no-brainer
that's something that should have been a
dressier many many many many years ago
and I think fortunately that's something
that will probably be universal the
banding the particularly banding of
chokeholds and I you would met if you
don't mind repeat the second question
that you asked me and the qualified
immunity that police now are given
towards justifying whatever they do
because they felt their lives are in
danger
yeah that is that is something that I
think that we need to take a look at it
needs to be modified
you know absolute immunity there are
obviously some issues with that but I
think it might be some opportunities
where that can that can be for
discussion and we can determine and it
can be determined which should be
qualified versus what is not qualified
versus everything that is followed by so
that is uh and I and I'm hopeful that
that will be a topic of discussion
versus eliminating it completely or
supporting it completely I think they
need to put it on the table and say this
the second that's it let's take a look
at this and what's the right way of
having qualified community if in fact
was going to happen
that's right well that's the debate
taking place this week in Washington in
Congress chief Farsi white thank you so
much for being with us today of valuable
insights coming up scammers on line one
what you need to know about all those
phone calls seem to take advantage of
the pandemic this is a call from the
Social Security Administration during
these difficult times of the coronavirus
we regret to inform you that we have got
in order to suspend your socials
immediately within 24 hours due to
suspicious and fraudulent activities
found on your socials we are contacting
you as this case is critical and needs
your urgent attention
all too often with every crisis comes
opportunities for crooks and that's
certainly the case during this pandemic
Americans are being cheated out of
millions of dollars as I learned when I
talked earlier with the Connecticut
Attorney General William Tom mr.
Attorney General thank you so much for
joining us these scammers they can't
help themselves it seems even during a
pandemic no they can't if this gives
them real opportunity as you know
scamming has become big business it's
cheap it's easy they can do it from
places not in Connecticut not in the
United States and many of us are at risk
and what can you do about it if they're
overseas so the biggest thing we can do
is work with our federal partners to
stop them when they try to scam us but
also really just to educate people over
and over again to hammer home the
message that if you get a phone call you
get a text message you get an email
offering you something that's too good
to be true
offering you something you've from
someone you've never heard from before
be careful be careful know what you know
which is that nobody's gonna call you on
the phone and ask you for your social
security number or your credit card
information they're definitely not gonna
call you and ask you to send them gift
cards and just be careful we have a
couple of the phone calls that's been
recorded by you and by the federal
authorities let's listen to a couple of
them starting with this one which where
they say your Social Security benefits
have been suspended this is a call from
the Social Security Administration
during these difficult times of the
coronavirus we regret to inform you that
we have got in order to suspend your
socials immediately within 24 hours due
to suspicious and fraudulent activities
found on your socials we are contacting
you as this case is critical and needs
your urgent attention yeah I mean people
right now given that many people have
either lost their jobs or working
reduced hours
or their small businesses are at risk or
shut down permanently or temporarily
people are really feeling insecure in
terms of their wallets and pocketbooks
and and financially people are at risk
and so any kind of scam that focuses on
taking advantage of you when you're
afraid of what the financial future is
for you and your family those are
particularly dangerous right now
and will the Social Security
Administration call you and say your
benefits have been suspended no no they
won't the IRS isn't going to call you
and tell you that unless you pay right
now several thousand dollars you're
gonna go to jail none of that is going
to happen and Brian I think people know
that but but the trouble is when you get
a phone call and you pick up a landline
or even your cell phone you get an email
and it looks legit it sounds legit or if
they just catch you at a weak moment
that's that's why it's scary good smart
capable people get scammed all the time
here's one where they say we've got free
delivery to you of centa cisors and all
sorts of things you need at your home do
your customer due to coronavirus
outbreak we deliver a wide range of
sanitizers hand wash toilet papers and
face masks at your doorstep to safeguard
you and your family from coronavirus no
need to visit stores get delivery in 24
hours to order press 1 for more
knowledge and safety tips about
coronavirus press 2 at the end they say
press 1 if you want it press 2 if you
don't what's the scam press 1 and press
2 is their gateway to get you on the
phone with a live person and that's that
opens the door to any kind of fast talk
about hand sanitizer masks cures access
to quick testing and then as you may
have heard there's a variety of
different scams related to stimulus
checks so by pressing 1 or 2 on any of
these calls that generally put you in
touch with a live person and it also
confirms with a scammer there's somebody
there there's a mark there and we should
work on them and here's one where they
say do you want a free
get response act has made coronavirus
testing more accessible immediately if
you want to receive a free testing kit
delivered overnight to your home press 1
if you do not want your free testing
price tip so and again they say press 1
if you want it press 2 if you don't
there's no free testing kid is theirs
there's no free testing kit there's no
cure there's no vaccine yet there's no
get get you know a test expedited
there's none of that the best way to get
tested is through your doctor through
your local hospital hospital or public
health officials don't trust any offers
to test you quickly give you a different
kind of test that's more effective give
you access to cures that nobody else has
access to again people note this and and
and they understand they're scammers out
there the trouble is you catch someone
when when they're not a great place and
they're worried about their family
members if someone's gotten sick or
they're desperate for information or
help that's when they get taken
advantage of how are these scammers
getting the phone numbers they use to
call and make the pitch Oh
variety of ways many of them are cold
calling many of them canvass publicly
available information and data and many
of them have access to big data so all
of us know that when we log into our
computers now that big data enables
major retailers and organizations
advocacy organizations to reach out to
us they know we're searching for example
if you look I like to fish so if you
look at if you're a Field & Stream
subscriber for example somebody knows
that you like to fish and so they'll
send you a bunch of a bunch of offers
around fishing you know if you're into
current events or I'm a Democrat you
know and I read articles and sign up for
websites or organizations that tend to
be aligned with my point of view and my
political affiliation
big data enables other people to access
that information and target you so then
access to that kind of data data they
can target you they might know that you
for example if you're over 65 and you
have four grandchildren they might be
able to figure that out if they see that
you're a mom and you're always looking
online for information related to health
care and children's health care they can
target you on that basis here's a call
that targets people with student loan
debt saying that will take care of the
waving of the student loan payments
Gordon message regarding the effects of
the corona virus outbreak on your
student loans because you may have
already heard a president Trump invoked
his power as commander-in-chief by
declaring a national emergency due to
the widespread impacts of private 19 new
measures will include waiving interest
on your federal student loans until
further notice for more information on
how these new measures will impact your
future payment obligations call us back
today are you going to get a cold call
like that from the government about
getting rid of your student loan
payments no you're not gonna get a cold
call about waiving your student loan
payments again that's a the
too-good-to-be-true
category right and the government
doesn't have the resources to call each
and every person to offer to give them
money back so again I say that only to
emphasize that we know these things and
we just need to as I say to people and
Connecticut know what you know and if
you get a phone call or an email or a
text message take a deep breath another
scam we haven't talked about our
charities people are really concerned
about people in their community and
charitable contributions and they want
again they want to be helpful in this
day and age but if someone calls you and
asks you for money on the phone don't
give it out right away take a deep
breath check with your local Consumer
Protection Department or your attorney
generals to off this and make sure that
they're a legit charity and you should
give money to them in addition to the
scams that come in by phone you're also
investigating other bigger frauds and
bigger crimes right sure so we have a
lot of work trying to protect people on
online platforms yeah major scammer
activity going on on
the major online marketplaces like
Amazon and eBay and other places we're
looking at the way people are treated by
major travel companies hotels Airlines
cruise ship companies and making sure
that if people have a right to cancel
their trips or get some kind of relief
or refund that they have access to that
and they're not being abused of course
the work of my office focused on even
bigger scams and frauds like the generic
drug price-fixing case that I'm leading
on behalf of 51 states and territories
that work continues as well so there's a
lot of money to be made by the scammers
and it's not just we think sometimes
just the elderly who fall victim to this
is it no it it happens to everybody it
happened to my mom I'm starting to say
she's a pretty savvy
she's a pretty savvy immigrant
businesswoman you wouldn't want to mess
with my mom but you know they caught her
on a bad day and she was swindled out of
several thousand dollars related to the
renting of an apartment that she rents
to people so everybody is at risk
everybody can be a target and again we
need to be careful and know that nobody
is gonna call you who's legitimate and
ask you for money in the spot credit
card number no one's gonna call you and
ask you to send them gift cards and no
one's gonna offer you something that is
is is not generally and widely available
to everybody else so again some some you
know get tested faster scheme or
get-rich-quick scheme or get your
stimulus check quicker any of those
scams are recognizable because it's just
not believable that you would have
access to this and nobody else would and
you would get it through a random phone
call and is there a place somewhere that
our viewers can go online to see if
they're being dealt with by scammers
sure you can always go wherever you're
listening from you can are watching from
you can go to your local Department of
Consumer Protection usually that's a
state agency or the office of your
Attorney General in Connecticut this
should go
to our department of consumer protection
website or to my website CT govt /ag
it's the same in other states and we're
here to help
Attorney General William Tong thank you
so much for your time and for your
advice
Thank You Bryan really appreciate it
coming up next
this week's winners and losers in the
media see if you agree without the
editors of media I'd have to say about
Fox and Friends you're watching the law
and crime trial Network and we close out
tonight's program with this week's
winners and losers in the media as
chosen by the editors of meteorites
joining us is Aidan McLaughlin who's the
editor in chief of media which like the
law and crime network is part of the Dan
Abrams
media empire Aidan thanks for being here
hey Brian let's start with your first
winner Paula Reed of CBS News okay thank
you all very much
well that was quite a shouting miss what
was going on there with Paula Reid yes
Paula Reid the CBS News reporter white
house reporter she's been known to sort
of shout out a pretty aggressive
questions at president Donald Trump and
this one we thought was particularly on
point now just to give a little context
that comes in the wake of the president
basically attacking John Bolton his
former national security adviser over
the memoir that John Bolton put out
which was highly critical of the
administration now Trump has dismissed
John Bolton as a wacko a nutcase a war
monger
he's called him a liar and he actually
called this morning on Twitter for him
to be put in jail so Paula Reid asked
the president why do you keep hiring
people that once you avenged
once they eventually leave the white
house you turn around and called them
them wackos
and it's a really good question not only
because of John Bolton but because there
is a long line of administration
officials who have joined the White
House President Donald Trump dicks told
their career and their intellect and
then once they depart the White House
and are at all critical of the
administration President Trump labeled
them dumb as a rock to Rex Tillerson the
former Secretary of State was called
dumb as a rock by President Donald Trump
after he left the administration you
know we actually wrote a story compiling
all of the former administration
officials who president Donald Trump has
criticized as idiots once they've left
the administration and it's a shockingly
long list so President Donald Trump
didn't answer there why he is now
calling john bolton a wacko but Kayle
mcenany tries to offer some sort of
Defense in a press briefing a few days
later she says that President Donald
Trump likes having differing views which
is sort of an interesting way to spin it
amazing well it's a pertinent question
with no answer of course you also chose
as a loser the Trump campaign tell us
why yeah so I this one's kind of
interesting because we actually named
the Trump campaign loser on Friday
before the disastrous rally that Trump
had in Tulsa Oklahoma on Saturday night
which the campaign was blamed for pretty
pretty harshly at least in reporting
there's reports now the president Donald
Trump is furious with the campaign
manager Brad Park ow um but we actually
made them lose her on Friday which was
before the rally and it was over two
slaps on the wrist that the Trump
campaign got from social media the first
was from Twitter when the when President
Donald Trump posted on his Twitter feed
a video of a manipulated CNN segment it
was basically a parody CNN segment which
was trying to cap enn at stoking racial
division but it was sort of an ugly
video and it had sort of ugly undertone
ugly racial undertone um and it was of
course a completely made-up CNN segment
so CN a Twitter excuse me basically flag
that tweet and took down the video
saying that it was sort of manipulated
and it was misleading so that was the
first slap on the wrist that president
Donald Trump got from Twitter which is
his favorite social media platform the
other one came to the Trump campaign and
that was on Facebook now the Trump
campaign posted a series of sponsored
ads on Facebook warning against antifa
you know basically accusing the sort of
group of being a grave threat to the
United States and in a lot of the ads
they use this upside-down red triangle
which you can see here now people
pointed out that the inverted red
triangle is a symbol that was used by
the Nazis
now the Trump campaign says that it's
also a symbol used by Antipa either way
Facebook said that they don't tolerate
hate them both being used on their
platform and they took down all of those
ads from the Trump campaign so it was a
real you know strong broadside against
the Trump campaign by social media last
week and given how much the Trump
campaign used Facebook in the 2015
election to get their message out it's
it must be alarming for the Trump
campaign to know that Facebook is
actually going to be cracking down on a
lot of their messaging a bad week for
the Trump campaign your next winner was
Fox and Friends let's take a look at
what they had to say but at the same
time we are at during a global pandemic
and I don't know who thought it was a
good idea to put 20,000 people in a room
and the with masks optional surprise
from Fox & Friends
yes you know Fox and Friends everyone
knows it as President Donald Trump's
favorite morning show it's very very
generous to Trump and his administration
but they actually last week spent a good
amount of time questioning Republican
official officials as to the wisdom of
President Donald Trump holding a large
rally indoors in Tulsa Oklahoma while
the corona virus pandemic still spread
now that was no different when in the
aftermath of the rally on Monday when as
you can see Steve Doocy there who is you
know not a frequent critic of the
president asking who thought it was a
good idea to cram thousands of people
into a rally now bear in mind
you know only 6,000 people showed up as
a lot of people have pointed out the
rally was not as packed as president
Donald Trump was hoping which you could
argue was a good thing during a national
pandemic or a global pandemic I should
say but you know Fox and Friends raising
the question of you know during this
time holding a rally that runs counter
to the Trump administration and the
government's own guidelines about social
distancing and and maintaining small
gatherings as opposed to large ones it's
just not a good idea and it's good to
see the president's favorite morning
show actually push back on that
wonder what he has to say about that it
must be a shock to him the next loser
was a well-known newspaper in Tennessee
The Tennessean explain why they are
losers
yeah so this is a sort of wild one this
Tennessee and the newspaper printed a
full-page ad from a religious group a
Christian group that was that basically
accused Muslims of planning a an attack
on the United States in July it was an
ad that had president Donald Trump and
the Pope at the top of it it said that
Muslims were planning this attack and
the president Donald Trump would be the
last President of the United States so
it was a really crazy and sort of
conspiracy theory Laden ad that was
published in the full page in this
Nashville newspaper and somehow it got
past the newspaper editors and made it
to print I was printed in a Sunday
edition of The Tennessean now you know
the editor of the paper the publisher
all profusely apologized but it raises
some real questions as to how this made
it to print you know all of these ads
should be vetted to make sure that you
know that they're not spreading
falsehoods that they're not sort of you
know the nutcase conspiracy theories
aren't making it into full-page ads in
major you know newspapers that are the
top newspaper in the state so you know
they've pledged to do better I think it
probably has a lot to do with budget
cuts at newspapers across the country
you know they don't that not only are
their copy desks getting eroded at
newspapers there's also a lot less
oversight on what goes into the paper so
I'm hoping that The Tennessean make some
changes
and I see where they fired and a head
manager and said they will contribute
the $14,000 or so they received in
revenue for running the ad to a Muslim
group yeah which is a really really good
step but again there really needs to be
some you know more efforts made to
fortify you know who is overseeing these
papers to make sure that you know this
kind of stuff doesn't go to print it's
not really about one person I think it's
about her you know budgets being cut at
these newspapers absolutely age
McLaughlin's the editor chief of media I
thank you so much for joining us thank
Ryan and thanks to all of you for
watching Jesse Weber will be here
tomorrow we'll be back next week and
thanks to all our staff for getting us
on the air and off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]